a state visit between the leaders of the
United States and Australia overshadowed
by questions of political impropriety by
US President Donald Trump I've had
conversations with many leaders that
always appropriate from the Oval Office
Trump defended and downplayed the
allegations he abused his position of
power during a phone conversation in
July with Ukraine's president
Vladimir's olenski allegedly asking him
to investigate a Democratic presidential
opponent former Vice President Joe Biden
it doesn't matter what I discuss but I
will say this somebody ought to look
into Joe Biden's statement because it
was disgraceful somebody ought to look
into that and you wouldn't because he's
a Democrat but that phone call has now
become the focus of a congressional
investigation following a whistleblower
complaint from the inside the
intelligence community one the Trump
Justice Department reportedly tried to
block Democrats accused the Trump
administration of a cover-up that whole
purpose is being frustrated here because
the Director of National Intelligence
has made the unprecedented decision not
to share the complaint with Congress
Democrats alleged Trump may have tried
to help his presidential reelection
campaign by pressuring Kiev to
investigate business deals between
Ukrainian companies and Biden son will
Biden was vice president according to
the Ukrainian government Trump expressed
support for their efforts to investigate
corruption during a phone call with
zalenski in July shortly afterwards the
u.s. reportedly began reviewing the
possibility of suspending 250 million in
military assistance to Ukraine the White
House announced this month it is
providing the money to Kiev Trump says
the accusations are politically
motivated it's just another political
hack job after initially dodging
congressional requests president Trump's
Acting Director of National Intelligence
has now agreed to testify next week
before Congress about the whistleblowers
complaint this as president Trump
continues to deny any wrongdoing
we'll also scheduled to meet with
Ukraine's president next week
at the United Nations General Assembly
Kimberly hellcat al Jazeera the White
House